okay okay
um as chairman of the house commerce and
consumer affairs committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the coven
19 pandemic in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
and pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar
today an executive session may be held
on any bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporariously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporariously
listen and if necessary participate in
the meeting by zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem assessing the
meeting shall call 271
3600 or email hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all the votes taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
and let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence
please also state whether there's
anybody in the room when you're
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
ah there we go and then nick of time
just in the nick of time all right
going keys we're ready we're ready for a
roll call
mute there he goes there we go
all right here we go representative hunt
here and i'm alone representative
here and i'm alone upstairs
representative osborne here home alone
representative amman uh here alone wife
representative hamm here alone
representative de palma here alone
representative recent recent president
alone
all right representative johnson you're
in my cabin in louisiana
nice on the ball on board somewhere i'm
on a business trip
representative terry i am here
solitarily
representative bartlett i'm here alone
representative abel here and alone
muted muted story of his life
here hello everybody
uh here alone in my room and my wife is
working from home elsewhere okay
representative van halton present alone
representative fargo i'm here and
i'm outside alone there are workmen in
the house
refinishing our floors
representative weston i'm here alone in
my office
representative
representative burroughs here alone in
and representative mcelroy here alone in
the house
okay so that's 17 president western
okay and uh
as they call it in the senate uh we have
pairing today
one republican one senator is missing
when one republican when democrats
missing
okay um all right so we have three bills
and so we'll get get going on this um
first one
is um senate bill 66 uh we passed it
uh with a vote of 17 to two
was gonna be on the consent calendar uh
so representative nam
seconded by representative patusik uh
moves that we
reconsider our action on senate bill 66
is this which which bill uh this is the
on-premise transportation wines for
delivery
and we had right now the bill was to
take
we we first amended it to remove the
sunset
but it turns out uh the governor's order
is now
a problem because uh it's now currently
it's it's
legal to do this for restaurants to do
it under the governor's order but the
evidence order is expiring
or expired or is going to expire but the
liquor commission said they would honor
it until july
1st so uh this new amendment we hope to
take up will be
to uh allow to be um become law upon
passage
which we're assuming the governor will
sign it before july 1st
so there will be no lapses in the in the
statute
okay uh see no discussion
the clerk will call the role on
reconsideration
assuming you have that on your list it's
not even on the forum but i'll figure it
out
um her representative
yes representative osborne yes
representative hammond yes
representative abramson
yes representatives of palma yes
representative yes
yes representative terry
yes representative bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative herbert yes
representative van halton
yes representative fargo
yes representative weston
representative burroughs yes
we still didn't hear ya that's
spacebar only works sometimes yeah yeah
yeah representative hunt
yes okay 17 to zero
uh okay was it would it be eighteen
seventeen
how many members okay
and i see two that's right nineteen
right missing two okay seventeen
do you think after a whole year and get
used to this one okay
uh all right so um uh
representative uh ham well i'll say my
name is on it so it's a representative
hunt second by representative patusik
moo's amendment number one four
and i will speak to my motion the
amendment just simply says
uh the effective date shall take effect
upon its passage
any discussion on the motion of the
amendment
to ought to pass on the amendment see
okay just one second here no problem
who's got the nice bird in the
background me
it must be tina she's out sorry i can't
representative patusik yes
representative osborne yes
representative amman yes representative
hamm
yes representative de palma
yes representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes representative abel
yes representative herbert yes
representative van halton yes
representative fargo yes representative
weston
representative burroughs yes
representative
mcaleer yes representative hunt
yes and i think i skipped abramson
he's not here and that's 17-0
now i don't care to write the blurb on
that
okay uh representative patusik second by
representative ham
moves uh uh to pass on senate bill 66
as amended is there any discussion on
and that was patusek you're too sick and
ham
okay john didn't we just do
66 we just did the first we did
reconsideration we did
66 you know 10 days ago
but we needed to add another amendment
which was to have a
effective upon passage so the vote we
just did
is was the amendment but the vote prior
to that was to reconsider our
action when we did have passed ought to
pass as
as amended sorry i got bogged down in
the process
i don't mind describing the details here
so the motion is all to pass as amended
correct
all right uh representative patusik
yes representative osborne
if representative am and yes
representative ham yes
representative de palma yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett
yes representative abel yes
representative berber yes representative
van houghton
yes representative fargo yes
representative weston yes representative
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer yes
and representative hunt yes
17-0 okay all those in favor of placing
uh senate bill 66 on the consent
calendar please say aye aye
aye oh supposed you man
i'm sorry petusik we'll work the blurb
yeah yep i'll have that in this
afternoon
okay aren't you good some of us need
reminders
sorry i'm not going to go on consider i
do have my list here we'll
go over that after we get this all done
okay
uh next is senate bill 97 relative to
health insurance uh
so we never actually did any vote on
this one because we knew we needed
another amendment okay so uh
representative de palma who had my notes
and
second by representative batusex moves
off the pass
1606 six
this amendment numbers are climbing
other committees are really busy okay
um so in discussion on the amendment
this is the uh tyler this is the
and um
the other important thing is is that it
still did what the other amendment did
which was to remove section one of the
bill so if you have it in front of you
you'll see
it says line five says amend the bill by
replacing
all after the enacting clause that's
really important because that basically
says
we're starting afresh now guys so number
one is the pharmacy benefit manager
section
and two uh is the relative to the health
carriers
which is they that have which is really
where um
tyler's amendment is and then three is
the effective date
okay is everybody comfortable with that
yep
okay the clerk will call the roll on
octopass on the amendment
yes representative osborne yes
representative amid yes representative
abramson
representative hamm
yes representative de palma
yes representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett um yes on the
amendment
representative abel yes
representative herbert yes
representative
van gaalton yes
yes representative weston
yes representative bellew
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear
yes and representative hunt
yes seven zero okay amendment passes
17-0
uh representative palma second by
representative patusek moves out to pass
as amended any discussion on the motion
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair i'm trying to
remember why
i was uncomfortable with this one and
um i'm looking at my notes well
originally my memory was that you guys
were
confused whether the pharmacies were
okay with it
rick newman rick newman represents the
independent pharmacists
okay and and curtis represents the
okay and so tyler has
taken out section one
completely because i that was the part
that was a problem
right problematic or i've got
heidi kroll opposing section one new
hampshire insurance plans
does that sound right um yes
okay yeah was it that the direct care
one
what was what was that section one
um yes it was a direct care one
yeah primary care referral parody so
that's all gone
okay and representative burroughs
was concerned i guess that was section
one as well
does that sound right to you
representative burroughs
yes okay so it looks like we're okay on
okay just you know the details on this
stuff get
you know it's so important to me that
everybody understands what we're voting
on what we're thinking you know and so
there's no
questions you know that we don't well i
appreciate that
uh mr chair because we you know had a
number of bills that
have had different parts to it correct
and
as representative abramson points out we
don't like it when the senate does that
to us
no we don't like that but i guess it
will cope
so it might make their lives easier but
it doesn't make our lives
okay and i do have curtis's email here
regarding okay regarding 97 specifically
and solely part two
okay got it got it okay okay i'm bored
the motion is ought to pass as amended
the clerk will call the roll
and just remind her it was uh de palma
and hunt
department
okay calling the wall
what to pass as men did 97 senator
knightson
representative yes
yes representative ammon yes
representative evenson
representative hamm
representative palmer yes
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
yes representative herbert
yes representative van houghton
yes representative fargo yes
bellew
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt
okay votes past 17
this is zero all those in favor of
placing on the consent calendar please
say aye
aye and those opposed
move unanimously okay last but not least
senate bill 107
financial assistance for businesses
jacob 19.
representative ham second by
representative patusek moves in
expedient to legislate
um i assume all of you got taylor
caswell's letter
and that this was obviously a very
obscure situation
and the way the main street program had
to run
but going forward there's plenty of
money in any business whether you're old
new or
just open can take advantage of the you
know whatever the new rules would be
federal
uh so representative ben do you have a
question
more comment uh actually i have a
comment first of all thank you for
for reaching out to taylor caswell i
realized i had an obscure question that
i that i put out to you
i'm getting a message i've just recently
got a message from one of the sponsors
and it says the bill is still relevant
there may be more discretionary fed
funds coming
and the state may put them in the main
street program
in that case we need newer business to
be eligible for the funds
also the business that we created post
may 26
2019 are now 12 to 18 months older
when original funds come so they will be
in the same position of businesses when
the first round of money came
so in essence i'm getting a message from
the sponsor that this is probably still
something that we should vote on
as one of the co-sponsors i believe let
me look who who who is it
you're getting it from uh representative
macbeth
macbeth okay well okay
um what taylor said i don't have her as
a sponsor
i'm sorry yes are you sorry i believe
she may be on and since we had a
suspended testimony would you like to
invite her to clarify what i just read
to you
oh that'd be great i don't really
want to do that because then it's then
when really it's taking testament i i
i'm uh rebecca i hope you understand but
but um i
i i this is this is for this exact
session this is not appropriate
well we've had a lot of questions the
only time we ever have gone
to allow someone from the public to
speak is usually
someone from the department or someone
who has a specific uh question in terms
of the bill
as a as a co-sponsor of the bill that
yeah she wants to see a bill passed and
i understand that
but then we're going to get into
conversation back and forth about it
and i i really i really don't want to do
that today
um i'm in all due respect rebecca i mean
becky you know i would never
you know it's not about you it's about
it's just the process
and um that but taylor cosmo said it
very specifically is that
in any new money that's coming down is
it won't be the main street program it
will be determined by the
the requirements of whatever the federal
strings and as we've learned already
is that there will be a lot of strings
attached to any money that's coming down
and their business is going to be
following along that
but uh but that it's not the main street
program is done and over with
so um you are you all said connie are
you still have your hand up or
um no um i just want to clarify why i
asked for that it was because we
suspended the testimony we didn't
i thought we had not completed the
testimony and that it would be fair
since we had not completed the testimony
to allow someone else who wished to
testify
so that's hearing from the hearing yeah
we defended it
we were going to follow up on my
question to taylor and i don't know
that's the exact session
yeah that's not a hearing that was the
exact session was it yeah you're great
ended the exact exact session on that
i'm taking action on that bill
so that you could hear directly from you
know taylor himself and what um
whether the main seat program uh would
ever be used or
you know i mean frankly this is just
feel-good legislation
i mean i you know i know people want to
pass something i want to know
and people want to say oh we did
something for but this doesn't this
it just it says urges it's not even
it's not even a mandate it's like a
you know as you all know what i think of
resolutions
and this is just a resolution really but
anyway representative bart uh bartlett
you have your hand up yes
yes um i mean we had 68 in favor of this
with nobody opposed
we passed feel good legislation all the
time
i don't see i i don't understand why
this would not be a a good bill to pass
because it does also
um signal our intention to those that
are
setting up you know if there is no money
left in this program to setting up the
next program
this this affects constituents
it doesn't this this isn't this is a
meaningless piece of legislation it did
all it does is
urge it doesn't do anything
and and and why why do we want to
clutter up our statutes with something
that doesn't do anything
oh come on we don't have we have lots of
cluttered
uh not not with my vote i have i don't
know if you want to pick you'll find
somewhere
where i voted for clutter but uh you
know me personally i
i i want to see less laws not more
and i certainly don't want to see things
that urges you know something to happen
when when obviously the the governor's
office and every and
everybody was conscious of what happened
and and
understand that the main street program
had had a shortcoming
because it was based upon having to do a
look back
but you know having that ever happen
again i just don't think it happened but
i don't know you can vote
any way you want to vote so um
representative mr chairman
mr chairman um i'm i'm confused are we
effectively
it sounds to me like we're reopening
debate on this or
are we or is this just a question of
process
i thought we're in executive session we
are an exec session and
i i i allow each person to speak
um and as long as it's speaking towards
the bill then then it's appropriate
it sounds like a substantive discussion
on the merits of the bill though am i
mistaken no that that's what we do in
the exact session
okay so so thank you good try
but uh but no this is this is the merits
of the bill and if they
you know if they think that that they
want this
legislation to pass then they have their
entitled to their opinion
so uh is anybody else who hasn't had a
first chance to speak want to speak
otherwise i'll go back
to the same all right representing van
houghton you have your hand up again
i do and my final comment is simply that
um
the pandemic has thrown us such a
curveball in so many ways
that if we leave a door open for
potential problems
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that especially when we're talking
about business
and we're talking about a whole host of
uh of sponsors and co-sponsors
both from the house and the senate who
um
set this up for that purpose so i would
i will be voting um in that manner and i
will encourage my colleagues to do so as
well
okay and representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um i'm a little
confused about where this part
is that you're talking about urging this
says to the extent permitted by federal
law
federal relief funds received by the
state of new hampshire to assist
businesses affected by coveted pandemic
shall be shall be made available to
businesses that were not eligible for
grants in the main street relief
fund this this is a shell
it's so saying that that it uh well
again if that if you want to just leave
it on that thing
that would mean is that
there cannot be a main street program
if they use the same requirements right
so i'm saying is
the main street program is done it's
over with it's gone
the federal government is coming down
with new programs so there's no
it's done it's over with you know you're
that's why i mean it's just you know
you know urging when i say urging is
that you know hopefully
uh you know that that you would
because i think it's a mistake that they
use the word main street they should
have said
is that any any programs make sure that
to the full extent of the federal
statute which is
true no matter what now evidently the
federal statute didn't make requirements
about how we were going to give out that
main street money
but under my understanding is now that
the new federal program the new federal
money
there's tons of strings attached there's
tons of guidance
that's being given about what you can
spend the money on
and so i don't i'm sorry i don't read it
that way so i'm going to have to oppose
the um otp representative abramson
you might want to check your microphone
too you're your speaker but yeah i'm
right here
you have two microphones or just the one
there's one in the room so it looks like
the
microphone in the room is also picking
you up yeah the community you may need
to
it looks like you're going to have to um
go over to the computer and unmute
yeah the committee room has to be muted
uh john are you able to unmute that what
um can i see i see
but brad knows but yeah so right now i
can only ask them
to understand unmuted
yeah okay so now now see what happened
was
it was yeah so now it looks yeah now the
microphone is open so it should work now
max
do you want to call out to us and say
hello can you folks hear me now
yes great you're sitting in the german
seat right well this is where the
microphone is
that's that's why it has the god reverb
going
i just wanted to say that uh i was here
in the room
but uh i've been having some technical
problems trying to get into the uh
the zoom meeting so um audio and whatnot
uh
and i i still want to leave the question
open again it's not a rhetorical
question
for any of the supporters of the bill is
does this actually affect anyone
is there actually any business that
might benefit is there any money in the
main street relief fund
you know passing this bill actually do
anything
okay we'll call that as hey would you
believe
uh that's an actual question that's a
it's an actual question for anyone who
supports the bill
does the bill actually do anything i've
i've left that open since the original
public hearing and i
okay uh i guess nobody has their hand up
so is there any more discussion on the
motion of an expedient to legislate
representative the motion is for itl
right mr chair yeah
it's yes representative osborne
yes representative amman yes
representative
abramson aye representative ham
yes representative de palma
yes representative greeson
yes representative johnson
yes representative terry yes
representative abel no
representative van gaalton no
representative fargo no
representative bellew
representative burroughs now
representative mcaleer no
representative hunt yes
okay that's eleven to seven okay
connie do you want to do it or do you
you're muted thanks you can do it uh
i'll be glad to support you in that but
okay i'll do the minority i'll give it
to you today
okay and the report is ought to pass
it is thank you okay
so before we all say goodbye um
yeah uh uh max are you still
yeah that's right i got it i'm all set i
don't know we're in good shape for
for more uh reports just for the three
ones we did today we just need to get
these three done
and um and we'll take it from there
would it be okay with everybody if i
sent a little note to pam uh telling me
what we're thinking of her and
hope she knows quickly i'm sure she
would appreciate
committee definitely okay
okay uh max is your hand up for a reason
or you just i just put my hand i just
had a question uh
for the chair do we have any more bills
that could be amended or changed uh
that are bound for our committee or are
we done with everything all the two
committee bills um
we definitely i know i know we have one
uh
one of our liquor bills uh oh the uber
the uber or the doordash bill
593 yeah that that one they amended it
by
putting putting it back to 60 days upon
passage
and and that was by a request of
uber eats that they need they need the
time to
yeah get the contracts out and have
contra you know
so let's get my violin out yeah
that's a tiny one yeah
so i i was just gonna i'd concur with
that
and there's no reason to to rock the
boat on that one um
so but what uh when i get
bills that um uh will ask for uh
if there are senate amendments to them i
will send out a notice to everyone to
let them know
and and for you to you know let me know
what you think
how does everybody feel about that 593
changing it back to 60 days
right but it's a it's a new restriction
to
take effect historically we've always
allowed 60 days when there's any new
limitation restrictions
you find the the doordash and these
others have to respond to that
you know the rule has to go out yeah but
they're taking it
they're taking advantage of these people
right now and you're giving them 60 more
days to do that
well but they got to get the contracts
out so there is theoretically there
there's a chicken in the egg problem
there with these contracts where we're
mandating
and we have a contract you know you know
and no contract gets
negotiated overnight to have
so so but yeah so anita would did you
have i see your hands up
uh you gotta unmute yeah sorry about
that yeah when i came in you were asking
people about subcommittees are we all
set with that because i don't even
remember
uh i have you you you bur as business
okay perfect uh chris mccleary
did do you know what you want to do the
business is fine with me
okay uh i think i i think i got it we
have enough
insurance i've got too many democrats on
that you got to choose something else
how about insurance
chris your insurance would be fine too
what am i on i didn't i got in a
teeny little bit later i have you on
business okay
what do you have me on john and i
have oh well i have you blinked on so
what would you like to do
i have you as liquor yes representative
terry did you
you i have you as business
representative
how about one stop uh john
so uh for you
i don't yeah that's true i don't have
anything what do you want to do banking
if that's
john could you send those those lists
out to everybody
yes except as soon as i find out uh
so jason jason do you want to be on one
of one of the divisions
uh if you need me go ahead okay i'll
i'll let me see what i have to do and
then the only thing is i have is
jane's the only one i have left uh loose
but um so but so it looks like i'm up
i'll put her on liquor
yeah i don't have a sense of where her
um like her would be
that's that's good anyways because her
her father used to have a license
okay uh yeah so that that's
representative
yes connie yeah i just have two points
one on the concurrence
for the ubereats um i i still agree i
mean the situation would not have
existed without their
their doing without their stepping up
without any kind of a contract
and so i do object to concurrence and
secondly am i on
laker uh
[Music]
yes i have you on liquor thank you but
again i do want to
object to the concurrence right okay
uh so uh
henry vayu is texting me and says that
um we are
uh that the restaurants are okay well i
i i henry i understand that you guys
would be okay with the 60 days
but but yeah so he's saying that the
restaurants are okay with the 68s now i
get it no
dirt okay i gotta understand so he's
saying that the people who want this
bill which is the restaurants
they were okay with the 60 days because
they they certainly because you remember
it takes two sides to negotiate a
contract
and the last thing they want to do is
have the gun to their heads about
signing that contract
sooner than they want to so it makes
sense that both sides would
okay if the restaurants are okay with it
yes henry says he's just texting me
i'd withdraw my um this is a great real
world
certainly is trying to keep track of it
all right my objection stands
i think it's because i'm thinking of the
small restaurants that don't have much
of a voice in this
so my objection stands i realize it's
it's one pebble in the water but i'd
like to leave it there thank you
okay no problem all right
and with all with that um i guess we'll
see you all
uh couple of weeks next week or two
weeks
yeah next week in session this week's
session so